bonjour et merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france alors un accord dans
la journée c'est une possibilité ou de
la poudre aux yeux selon vous oui alors
attention parce que effectivement le
premier ministre britannique devait à 9h
ce matin a annoncé cet accord qui était
quasiment bouclé or une difficulté
dernière minute est apparu sur quel
sujet cette difficulté est apparue et
bien précisément sur la pêche la pêche
chinois viennent compliquer les
britanniques ont fait un énorme effort
depuis ce qu'ils acceptent pratiquement
une un chiffre de 25% des réductions de
quotas pour la pêche des européens dans
les eaux britanniques ce qui était une
sorte de ligne rouge pour les européens
mais qui est quelque chose d'acceptable
mais il y a des éléments dans cet écart
y ait toujours des détails qui peuvent
faire capoter un accord et en
particulier un détail qui est celui de
l'accès privilégié pour les pêcheurs
européens à d autres poissonneuses il
s'agit pas seulement d'avoir un accord
sur les autres de pêche au sens
territoriale ut m
mais de pouvoir accès aux eaux
poissonneuses or il semble que c'est sur
ce point qu'il ait des difficultés nées
en moi je crois qu'on peut dire
aujourd'hui qu'on va vers un accord
qu'on est dans la dynamique d'un accord
et cet accord sur les trois points
essentiels qui peuvent faisait débat est
quasiment acquis premier point la pêche
les britanniques ont fait l'effort de
continuer à ouvrir leur zoo aux pêcheurs
européens sur le plan de la limitation
de la concurrence faussée et bien là
aussi il ya un accord certes les
britanniques récupère la maîtrise de
leurs affaires récupérez la maîtrise de
leurs décisions en ce qui concerne leur
politique mais mais si jamais ils
divergeaient un peu trop par rapport aux
règles du marché unique et bien à ce
moment là les européens seraient en
droit d'avoir des compensations
adéquates
donc ça c'est très important
récupération de l'autonomie des
britanniques mais en même temps
sauvegarde du marché unique auquel les
britanniques britanniques auront accès
et puis dernier point un mécanisme
d'arbitrage qui est en train d'être mise
au point mais qui ne devrait pas poser
de difficultés
quoique très sincèrement ce qui s'est
passé en grande bretagne c'est à dire
l'aggravation de la situation sanitaire
en grande bretagne avec l'apparition
notamment de ses variantes du virus
qu'ovide 19 à peser sur le poids le
blocage notamment frontière ces files de
camions tout cela à faire en sorte que
finalement les britanniques se sont dit
il faut quand même qu'on débouche
européens et britanniques ont tous deux
convaincus étaient tous deux convaincus
qu'on ne pouvait pas risquer d'un accord
qui aurait été une catastrophe et qui
aurait généré à partir de 1er janvier
une situation de quasi chaos qu'est
l'art on est dans la tente bien
évidemment d'une déclaration officielle
mais si jamais il était confirmée
justement cet accord il devrait
permettre justement de limiter on va
dire la casse aussi bien du côté du
royaume uni que de l'union européenne
oui je crois que j'ai certains c'est
certain c'est certain il s'agit c'est
avant tout d'éviter la case de
surcharger la part qui est de faire en
sorte effectivement qu'on n'assiste pas
à partir du 1er janvier
je suis la situation de blocage
généralisé à la frontière est donc là
certainement on va dans le sens d'un
apaisement des relations entre l'union
européenne et le royaume uni une
certaine manière je dois avouer que
boris johnson a fait preuve d'une
certaine sagesse mais il risque d'avoir
un sérieux problème effectivement avec
son parti politique les conservateurs
et puis avec l'ailé droite de ce parti
qui est lui considère a finalement qui
n'a lâché prise
et puis il ya aussi à l'intérieur ne
s'est encore des dispositions qui
peuvent inquiéter les britanniques
car certes ces garde le contrôle sur
leurs rapports avec l'union européenne
ils perdent une certaine manière une
forme de souveraineté sur leur propre
territoire sur des fractions de leur
territoire je pense notamment à
l'irlande du nord je pense aussi à
gibraltar puisque pratique seulement à
l'intérieur de cet accord finalement on
règle la question de gibraltar et de
l'irlande du nord qui d'une certaine
manière sont un petit peu coupé du
royaume uni et ça c'est une nouveauté ça
veut dire que gibraltar
la question serait quasiment
clé par cet accord et en ce qui concerne
l'irlande du nord pour je le rappelle
qu'on a voulu préserver l'absence de
frontières entre l'irlande du nord avait
publié l'ordre
eh bien ces deux fêtes finalement
accentue un petit peu cet isolement de
ces deux portions de territoire
britannique cela peut générer
effectivement un grand mécontentement
donc globalement on est vers un accord
mais il faut encore attendre
alors en cas de nos deals on l'a bien
compris le royaume-uni perdrait beaucoup
plus que le zéro point sur le niveau
économique et sur le plan politique
comme est il le principal pour boris
johnson ce qu'il doit pouvoir dire à la
télévision
il doit pouvoir dire aux britanniques
voilà j'ai réussi à négocier un accord
par lequel nous allons pouvoir quitter
l'union européenne
en récupérant la maîtrise de nos
affaires d'un certain point de vue il
n'a pas tort ils n'auront pas tort
effectivement il aura récupéré cette
maîtrise de ses affaires mais c'est un
coup politique qui va être assez lourd
pour lui
car effectivement les oppositions à
l'intérieur de la grande bretagne et
notamment à l'intérieur du parti
conservateur risque d'être assez sévère
on l'a vu d'ailleurs dans les premiers
titres qui ont paru ce matin dans la
presse britannique
donc c'est la sphère politique la sphère
de la pêche avait essentiellement une
dimension politique beaucoup plus
qu'économique et c'est pour ça que boris
johnson qui n'est pas par définition un
technicien mais qui est plus politique
s'est rendu compte que finalement c'est
là dessus qu'ils risquaient d'être jugé
est donc maintenant cet accord va être
soumis il est soumise déjà aux
ambassadeurs des 27 pays membres
mais il est soumis à l'intérieur de la
grande bretagne aux différents partis
aux différents membres du cabinet de
boris johnson il y a encore des
vérifications à faire le jeu je rappelle
quand même si un accord qu'il fallait
mise 200 pages et si on prend les
annexes avec ça fait 2000 pages qu'il
faut vérifier
il faut que les britanniques puissent
vérifier eux-mêmes
le contenu de ces deux mille pages mais
aussi les 27 pays membres de l'union
européenne
et puis après il faudra la ratification
une ratification qui ne pourra pas
arriver il ya très peu de chances qu'ils
arrivent avant le 1er janvier
et donc on serait dans le cadre d'un
accord transitoire qui serait appliqué
mais sous réserve de ratification dans
les premières semaines du mois de
janvier
merci beaucoup françois houle et mathis
d'avoir répondu à nos questions je
rappelle que vous êtes journaliste et
spécialiste des institutions européennes